frère à béziers et carcassonne françois
mitterrand a évoqué les problèmes de la
viticulture et l'élargissement du marché
commun à perpignan discours plus
politique
l'ex premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste a sévèrement critiqué valéry
giscard d'estaing béziers carcassonne et
enfin perpignan trois étapes une journée
particulièrement chargée pour le
candidat du parti socialiste
bruno masure 10h30 au quartier latin
françois mitterrand quitte son domicile
en compagnie du directeur adjoint de son
cabinet jean glavany et retrouve pierre
son fidèle chauffeur et garde du corps
la course contre la montre commence le
bourget généralement atteint en moins
d'un quart d'heure le temps d'une revue
de presse à 120 à leur présent
aujourd'hui dans le jet de dix places
louées pour la durée de la campagne le
député joseph franceschini chargée de la
sécurité des déplacements
anne gaillard et une consoeur suédoise
prochaine escale avignon 50 minutes de
vol
le temps de jeter un oeil aux
hebdomadaires de lire julien gracq ou de
discuter avec les journalistes de cette
campagne qui n'en finit pas de finir la
fatigue non je la sueur monde assez
aisément
il me suffit de bien dormir et je dois
toujours bien 12h30 avignon vite vite
direction bagnols sur cèze où le ps
organise une fête de la rose sur le
thème des identités régionales
l'occasion pour le candidat d'applaudir
au cours du déjeuner des petites filles
humer les aussi deux plus grandes venus
de toutes les régions françaises
le candidat n'aura guère le temps de se
restaurer les militants le réclame pour
un bain de foule
ensuite c'est le premier discours deux
thèmes l'énergie la régionalisation en
coulisses tout est prêt pour rejoindre
l'aéroport
on est déjà en retard pour béziers
mettant en garde les gens laissent entre
leurs mains
17h30
nous arrivons à béziers dialogue avec
des chômeurs et des chômeuses suivie
d'un exposé que denis principalement sur
les problèmes de la viticulture
j'ai rencontré mes salles d'aude 19h
carcassonne 3e meeting suivi d'un
apéritif et d'un rapide dîner avec les
militants
la dernière étape de la journée
perpignan il est bientôt minuit et
françois mitterrand en termine son
quatrième discours de la journée il sera
de retour chez lui vers 1h30 2h comme
pratiquement chaque jour on est loin
vous le voyez de la semaine de 35 heures